-Our next guest
is an Emmy-nominated write
and comedian whose work you know
from "Saturday Night Live,
and her comedy special,
"Sam Jay: Three in the Morning."
Her new late-night series,
"Pause with Sam Jay"
premieres May 21st
on HBO and HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-If you really want to help me
just make the laws better.
Cheers to that [bleep]
They've established
a rule of white society.
-They want Aunt Jemima
off the syrup.
-I didn't even
know the narrative!
I thought Uncle Ben
was a rice tycoon.
I was proud to buy that rice
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Sam Jay.
♪♪♪♪
-What's up?
It's good to see you.
-Good to see you.
Welcome, welcome!
-This is cool.
-We've got a couch for you
and everything.
-Yeah.
-It is nice to have you
back in the building.
You worked here
for "SNL" for three years.
And I imagine,
which I want to talk about
your talk show,
has its own set of stresses.
When you come back, though
in the "SNL" building
on the "SNL" floor,
do you miss it?
Do you feel those old
stress tickles?
-A little bit.
I was walking down the hallway
like, "Oh, this is nice."
But then I remembered
it's Tuesday night,
and I was like, "I'm so glad
I don't have to deal with this."
I'm so glad I'm here
in this capacity.
-'Cause you're putting togethe
your own show.
And I imagine
one of the first things --
One of the coolest things
is staffing it.
Did you know right away
the kind of people
you wanted working on your show?
Were they people you'd known
through your life as a stand-up?
-Yeah. A lot of stand-ups
on the show.
I knew for sure I wanted peopl
that I would argue with
and who are good at screamin
loudly when they're drunk.
I was like,
I need those two things.
-And you had people like tha
in your life.
-Yes. I had them
immediately ready.
If you're a stand-up,
I think you got those people
on speed-dial.
-And there does seem to be
the element of the show
is there's --
exactly what you just said
There is this sort of
party atmosphere
and this debate atmosphere
Have you been someone
who has enjoyed
being argumentative with friends
over your life?
-Yeah, yeah.
I think my whole life,
I've always liked to argue
My family thought
I was going to be a lawyer
'cause they were like,
"Oh, 'cause you love to argue,
which, there's way more
to being a lawyer than that.
But ever since I was a kid
I was big into arguing, debating
and, you know, kind of pokin
the bear a little bit.
-So, you have this talk show
You get this offer
to put it together.
And you sort of decide on,
from that clip,
you know,
you put it in this party.
It's got this really nice
verite feel to it.
How did you come
and land on that as your format?
-Well, I mean, I don't know.
I just felt like, you know
like, you got the desk
locked down.
You know what I mean?
-Like, fully. It's got --
-Yeah, you know,
God of the desk.
So I was, like, "Hey,
let me try something else
that I haven't seen."
And also, I just felt like I'm
better in that type of a space
-When you're doing it,
and obviously, you know,
you're out there
and you're performing,
and you're not necessarily
looking directly in the camera
the way, you know, I think
conventionally a lot of us d
it.
But you know obviously later
you're going to be in the edit
Are you able
to sort of be loose and free
or, as the creator of the show
as the show runner,
are you also thinking in
your head while you're doing it,
"Okay, this is working here.
This isn't working there"?
-I think I'm thinking
a little bit,
but also being,
like, loose and free.
It's a little bit of a dance
of, like, enjoy the moment
but also, sometimes
I'm, like, directing a camera.
I'm like, "Go over there,"
you know what I mean?
"It's better over there.
I'm not really saying anything."
So it's a little bit
of doing both jobs.
-And is it also about
making all the other peopl
in the room with you
feel comfortable, as well?
'Cause you must want them
to have the freedom
to be as loose as they would b
if the cameras weren't there
-Yeah, 100%. That was, like,
super important to me.
Like, I was like, "Please don'
be, like, staging my friends
Don't move them.
Don't place them."
I didn't want any boom mics,
which drove everybody insane
'cause there's about like 13
individual mics going on at once
so the audio
sounds nuts to them.
But I just wanted people
to be as comfortable as possible
so they could, like,
truly be themselves.
-And I'm imagining
the longer you were doing it
the more that became the case?
-Yeah. The more you do it,
the more I'm chilling,
and I think if my vibe is chill,
then their vibe is chill.
-How has -- I'm assuming,
like a lot of stand-ups,
you've missed it this past year.
Are you getting back up
on stages again?
And how has the experience been?
-I am.
I'm back up at the Cellar.
I'm back up at The Stand,
and it's been great.
Like, I miss stand-up so much.
And especially doing this show
it's, like, super stressful,
and weirdly, standing up
in front of strangers
and telling my personal business
is a stress reliever for me.
So, it's helped
balance out that energy.
-Has it always been
a stress reliever for you?
Because I think for a lot
of people, the idea of,
especially as
an upcoming stand-up
in the rooms you mentioned
which are pretty famous room
with a lot of big names,
when did you cross
that threshold
of stopped being stressed
before you went onstage?
-Um, I don't really know
when it stopped.
One day, I just wasn't anymore
-Yeah.
-I think once I realized,
like, "I'm going to do this,
and I'm going to be doing it
for a while."
You know, I think
once that lands on you,
you're like, "Alright,
there's going to be good days,
and there's going
to be bad days."
-Do you feel like
audiences are better
for having been
away from live performance
or are they rusty, as well
-I think audiences
are laughing at anything.
I think it's easier
to make them laugh.
They're just so happy to b
outside. You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-Like, you can say whatever,
and they're, like, dying
laughing and, like, rolled over,
which is nice, but also,
sometimes, you're like,
"I don't know
if that was that funny."
-Right. [ Laughs ]
Well, it's really hard,
because I think, you know, look,
you don't want a dead audience
but you want a true audience
especially if you're tryin
to build material.
And it's really hard sometimes
you know, to have to admit tha
to yourself,
of, "I think literally anythin
would've worked tonight."
-Yeah, but I think,
like, you know,
New Yorkers are,
like, easily jaded.
So, people have been outside
for like a month.
I think they're over it.
-Yeah.
[ Both laugh ]
-So, I think we'll get
a real New York audience back.
-Yeah, exactly.
You started in Boston
doing stand-up,
which has a great stand-up
history, of course.
And you talk about this
in your special.
You know, I think less known
for having maybe as divers
a stand-up, you know, scen
as maybe other places.
As someone who's queer, someon
who's black, as a female,
like, what was that scene like
for you coming up?
-Ah, very white and very male.
[ Both laugh ]
Like most comedy scenes.
But I think, you know, it ha
its times where it was rough
But I feel it kind of, like,
can be rough to anybody.
It didn't feel particular
to me in any way.
But definitely, it can be
a little bit isolating
when you go in a show, and
you're the only Black person
You're the only woman.
You're the only gay person
And then it's just like
a bunch of, like, white dude
who know all the Red Sox
players. You know what I mean?
You're like, "I guess
this is what we're doing."
-Do you feel like, you know,
after you're a part of the scene
for a while, though,
and you get up
and you score in enough rooms,
you become part of the team?
-Yeah, for sure.
I think comedy is, like,
a equalizer in that way
where people just need
to see you do it enough
and be like,
"Oh, she's good at it,"
and then they kind of, like,
just bring you into the fold
-Did you manage to --
I mean, 'cause, again,
part of your show is very much
that talking with comedians.
And I think it's, you know, on
of those elements of stand-u
that people romanticize
all the time
is how, you know, comics
when they get together,
they spend a lot of time
after the show
hanging out and talking.
Did you miss that deeply
over this time
that we were all apart?
-Very much.
I think that was part
of what drove me
to make the show the way I did
was that I missed
hanging out with my friends,
and I missed arguing
with my friends.
And I was, like,
"Ah, I need this energy
to happen somewhere."
So, I think that was a littl
bit of, like, I was like,
"Mm, maybe I can get HBO to pa
me to hang out with my friends."
[ Both laugh ]
-That's very smart.
Do you tend to -- When you hav
arguments with your friends,
are you ever convinced
to their point of view?
Or do you feel like --
-Sometimes.
-Yeah? Okay, good.
-Sometimes. Not often.
I'm pretty stubborn.
-Right.
-I think most of the time,
it's agree to disagree.
But sometimes, I can be brough
over to the other side.
-Hey, you posted this photo,
which I have to ask you about.
This is you and Emmanuel Lewis
-Yeah.
-And he was a deejay
at the time?
-He was -- So, he was a judge --
He was a guest judge
at the Boston Comedy Festival.
-Okay.
-And then, he would, like,
deejay the after-parties,
which I think was, like,
a part of his deal.
I think he was like, "I won'
judge unless you let me deejay."
And he was a pretty dope -
All he played was,
like, booty-shaking,
like, Southern,
like, Atlanta music
and, like, Lil Jon and stuff
which was really awesome.
It was a great time.
I was very shocked by all of it.
I was shocked he was there
I was shocked he was a deejay.
I was shocked
we looked that much alike.
-Yeah.
-It was all very odd.
-That must be jarring,
especially when
you have photographic evidence
of it forever.
-Yeah, for real, especially --
He's, like, one of my heroes
as a kid.
Like, who didn't love "Webster"?
-Yeah.
And was he --
How was he as a comedy judge
-Um, kind.
I don't think
he really was like --
-That's a good thing to hear
because you don't want to hear
hard truths from Emmanuel Lewis.
-Nah, he was nice to everybody
He thought everyone was funny,
you know what I mean?
-Did you do a lot of gigs
where there would be
sort of celebrity comedy judges?
Because that doesn't seem
super fun.
-No, I haven't.
-Yeah. Okay.
-I've done two. One was that
and I did a festival in L.A.
and Sal from
"Coming To America"...
-Uh-huh.
-...he judged.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Yeah.
-Would you ever agree to be
judge for someone else's comedy?
-I don't think so.
-Yeah, I don't think
I'd want to.
-I feel like,
how do you do that?
Yeah, no, I don't think so
-Yeah, I just wouldn't tak
any joy in telling people --
-No. And I would be thinking
like, if I was up there,
I'd probably want
this person to shut up.
-Yeah. I think that's very nic
that both of us know that
about ourselves,
that we wouldn't
want them there.
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
I really appreciate it.
Congrats on the show.
It's really a delight to hav
you back in the building.
-Thank you so much.
You got really beautiful eyes.
-Oh, thank -- You know what?
They're here every night.
-It was good. I like it.
-And nobody says a word.
[ Laughter ]
That's a real theme
tonight, Shoemaker.
"Pause with Sam Jay" premieres
Friday on HBO and HBO Max.